ce soir je vais vous montrer quelque
chose que vous ne pourrez pas voir et
c'est justement parce que vous ne pouvez
pas le voir que vous le verrez
et pour commencer une petite question
quelle est la couleur de l'or jaune doré
oui vous avez raison
regardez j'ai dans cette fiole de l'eau
et des petites paillettes d'or un petit
peu comme dans une boule de neige et
l'or est bel est bien dorée mais moi mon
or il n'est pas doré moi mon or il est
cette couleur si moi mon or il est rouge
rubis évidence cette fiole de l'eau et
des nano particules d'or une
nanoparticule d'or sont des petits
grains de matières infiniment petit
invisibles à l'oeil
et pourtant je peux vous les montre et
j'ai été pris en photo et voilà ne sont
ils pas magnifique
cet or j'en ai entendu parler pour la
première fois à l'université en deuxième
année
j'arrive le matin elle en fit dans
l'amphithéâtre un petit peu fatigué des
révisions de la veille et je me souviens
du professeur qui entrent ils avaient
une splendide barbe blanche et ils
installent sur la table devant le
tableau une plaque chauffante avec un b
cher avec de l'eau dedans il des
mélanges de liquide il mais l'appareil
en marche
il commence son cours bon vingt minutes
plus tard sa solution qui était
transparente c'était de l'eau devient
rouge rouge comme mafieuse rouge rubis
rouge comme tedx il venait de fabriquer
des nanoparticules d'or j'ai été bluffé
je voulais en savoir plus la couleur
la couleur est bien la couleur vient
justement d'une interaction entre la
lumière et mais nanoparticules d'or on
appelle ce phénomène
la résonance de plasmons de surface
localiser j'en suis tombé amoureux après
quand je parle de mes nanoparticules
d'or aux gens autour de moi
généralement ils n'ont jamais entendu
parler et des fois ceux qui ont déjà
entendu parler y ont une vision un peu
une péjoration négative il y associe
fait à des risques sanitaires ou
écologiques et et je peux comprendre car
historiquement on a plein d'exemples de
matériaux qui se sont révélés dangereux
pour l'homme par exemple quelqu'un
reconnaisse cet objet alors c'est pas un
quiz le but du jeu c'était deviner que
c'était une fontaine une fontaine à eau
qui était vendu dans les années 1910 aux
états unis regardons la publicité et est
sauf
voici la santé ce que ça promet lisons
le petit texte alors le voici traduit
pour garder la santé vous devez
respecter les lois de la nature
elles sont simples et faciles à
respecter
mais si elles sont brisées la nature
vous fera subir une lourde peine à
chacun d'entre vous donnez vous dormez
beaucoup fait de l'exercice et
amusez-vous sainement éviter le
surmenage tout autre excès manger
sainement des animaux naturel respirer
de l'air frais et buvez beaucoup d'eau
fraîche vivifiante naturel radioactive
de radium spar oui cet objet vous
propose vous délivre de l'eau qui est
radio active et commencez pas à dire que
c'est quelque chose de purement
américain on avait la même chose en
france
tu auras dia une entreprise qui vendait
des cosmétiques à la même époque du
rouge à lèvres st et qu'est-ce que tu
auras dia va mettre dans ces cosmétiques
et bas du radium et du thorium
alors pour ceux qui connaissent pas ce
sont deux éléments chimiques extrêmement
radioactif et finalement ces cosmétiques
vous vous donnez rien d'autre que le
camp
c'était censé être sérieux là au final
quand on y pense
une simple ignorance naïve candide mêlée
à de la négligence a laissé place à une
catastrophe
et c'est ce qui a donné place
aujourd'hui à la méfiance population par
rapport à ce genre de nouveauté et ça se
peut se comprendre mais est ce que c'est
vraiment la faute du radium le radiant
n'est pas un problème en lui même c'est
l'ignorance qu'on en avait et on sait
aujourd'hui que face à l'ignorance il ne
faut pas l'écarter au contraire il faut
s'y intéresser sont approchés l'étudier
mieux le comprendre et bien profitons-en
fait connaissance faisons connaissance
avec mes nanoparticules alors je vous ai
déjà présenté les rouges qui sont de
l'or en forme de sphère
mais si au lieu d'avoir de l'or en forme
de sphère on imaginer tout petits
bâtonnets eh bien on arrive à être bleu
si au lieu d'utiliser de l'or je change
de métal et je vais chercher de l'argent
et bien ça peut être orange où ça peut
être violée ou ça peut être je crois
dans ma poche jaune
je vais mettre une photo ça va être plus
pratique vous pouvez voir sur la photo
qui va s'afficher que de manière
générale on peut avoir différentes
couleurs juste en changeant que ce soit
de l'or de l'argent et en changeant la
forme de ces particules on peut même
elle est un petit peu plus loin une
dernière chose dans ma poche
c'est une petite pastille et si on
regarde où vous demande de regarder la
feuille ici si j'approche la bastille au
dessus de mal on peut se dit bah tiens à
la pastille elle va être bleu et
pourtant si je vous montre la couleur de
la pastille est bien celle ci elle est
opaque et orange
ce phénomène s'appelle le bichromate
estime propriété des nanoparticules ou
la couleur de l'objet lui même va être
différent de son ombre
en revanche il ya quelque chose pour
faire transition il faut pas me faire
dire des choses que je ne dis pas
forcément ici je vous ai montré de l'or
au quai des nanoparticules mais je ne
dis pas qu'elles sont inoffensives
dans ce cas là c'est dans solution c'est
à dire que c'est dans le lot où c'est
dans de la matière qui est solide ça
pose pas vraiment de problème mais si
j'avais par exemple du mercure ou du
radium qui serait toujours radioactifs
il faudrait avoir plus de précautions
prendre plus de précautions pas ce
serait toujours dangereux mais au final
il faut juste on avoir un usage
approprié
il faut juste faire attention ben
justement à quoi peuvent servir ses
anneaux particules alors personnellement
j'aurai mon travail et universités
j'utilisais cet or pour développer un
capteur de gaz le capteur d'hydrogène
pour des applications en énergie mais ce
n'est pas de ça dont je veux vous parler
ce soir
ce soir je vais vous montrer que cet or
ce aussi votre trésor et pour ça j'ai
cette image
donc nous avons ici une cellule on voit
son corps en verre le noyau en bleu où
il ya la dnc le coeur de la cellule et
le petit tapis l'étoile rouge
oui oui ce sont les nanoparticules d'or
alors pourquoi des scientifiques se
sont-ils amusé à mettre mes
nanoparticules d'or dans leur cellule
eh bien il s'avère que cette cellule
c'est une cellule humaine et elle est
cancéreuse elle est malade
or les faits qui donnent la couleur
rouge à mon or va voir un autre effet
c'est que mes nanoparticules elles vont
chauffer alors pas beaucoup moins
mafieux
elle n'est pas chaude mais suffisamment
chauffer pour se chauffer cellules
cancéreuses et elle va mourir
les cellules saines elles vont survivre
j'ai enfin de compte dans cette fiole un
potentiel cure contre le cancer qui
aujourd'hui présente des résultats très
prometteurs pour les patients aux tests
cliniques
une manière générale les nanosciences et
nanotechnologies présentent des atouts
très intéressant qui peut vraiment
améliorer notre vie au quotidien et on a
appris beaucoup de choses ces dernières
décennies on ce que je peux vous dire
c'est que oui
lorsque vous vous réveillez le matin et
qu'à la radio il annonce un pic de
pollution à la particule il faut
s'inquiéter parce que là oui elles sont
dangereuses mais il ne faut pas pour
autant complètement écarté la science il
faut pas se faire avoir par les jolis
mots il faut pas se faire avoir par le
marketing prenons un exemple tout bête
on est tous à peu près d'accord que
manger naturel est considéré comme une
bonne chose mais ce n'est pas suffisant
le tabac c'est naturel le radium c'est
naturel et pourtant
et ça d'esprit critique fossiles
appliquée que ce soit aux ogm au bio que
ce soit au réchauffement climatique etc
et c'est finalement avec l'éducation et
l'esprit critique
on va avoir confiance en la science
confiance en nos chercheurs et ça va
générer d'innovation qui va générer
encore plus de connaissances pour les
personnes ici ce soir qui justement être
scientifique est chercheur est
académique
indépendamment de la discipline j'ai une
faveur à vous demander
ne laissez pas les non experts parler en
notre nom
ne laissons pas un vide que n'importe
qui ou même n'importe quoi depuis
s'occuper il nous faut tendre la main
comme ici ce soir à tedx il faut être
accessible il nous faut être ouvert et
pour ceux dont ce n'est pas le métier
ceux d'entre vous qui n'êtes pas un truc
qui ne travaillent pas à l'université
n'hésitez pas à nous faire confiance aux
frais nous votre votre confiance
mais même en pratique venez à notre
rencontre est vraiment devenir d'avis
tous les jours c'est vous pouvez nous
envoyer un mail en vous posant vos
questions
est ce que tout ce savoir toutes ses
connaissances elles sont deux doivent
être accessibles à tous parce qu'elle va
faire la beauté de notre monde et le
patrimoine de notre humanité
en fin de compte pour en revenir à mes
nanoparticules c'est un petit peu comme
les gens
il y en a des bons il y en a des mauvais
et on peut même en tomber amoureux
merci
[Applaudissements]